cobalt mined by children's hands and
dangerous and dirty conditions in the
Democratic Republic of Congo filmed by
Sky News cobalt is one of 40 minerals
that end up in smartphones big flood
yeah you've got part of a bewilderingly
complex global supply chain from
suppliers to smelters factories assembly
lines finally it ends up in our own
hands the clean blank modernity of the
digital revolution erases its grim
origins what they need to be doing and
companies should be doing is engaging
with their suppliers to improve improve
the conditions at the mine site to
remove children's from the mines so that
mining really can be a source of growth
and jobs instead of insecurity and child
labor these are called artisanal mines
and they provide a livelihood to about a
fifth of the population in the DRC
they're also open to abuse Sky News film
children as young as four working in
appalling conditions the cobalt they
mine ended up being bought by a Chinese
cobalt mining company called yuc diem
why you told us they had immediate plans
for improving the situation but we asked
them three times if they would apologize
for using child labour but just Oh so-so
why you isn't sorry oh I don't want to
say in that way you understand we are
proud of our our our work in DRC and the
local guys also we have a very good
reputation and also the Sky News you are
more than welcome to tell us what we
should do to help to improve this
situation cobalt is mainly used for
batteries in smartphones laptops and
electric cars some of Hawaii's cobalt
went to third-party battery makers their
batteries ended up in Apple's products
Apple told me they've now instructed why
you to stop sourcing cobalt from
artisanal mines until they can be
verified
they also said Apple is deeply committed
to the responsible sourcing of materials
for our products and we've led the
industry in establishing the strictest
standards for our suppliers we were the
first company to map our cobalt supply
chain down to the mine and 100% of
smelters are participating in
independent third party audit the
company has also launched initiatives on
the ground with NGOs like pact more than
a lot of tech and auto companies bother
with most just rely on questionnaires
and surveys filled out by their own
suppliers Tesla BMW Renault Samsung and
Dell all told us that as far as they
knew no cobalt from why you entered
their supply chains the average
smartphone has around 10 grams of cobalt
let's call that a teaspoons worth now
laptop batteries have more around three
times as much 30 grams so call that a
tablespoon there when it comes to
electric car batteries we're not talking
spoons talking buckets around 10
kilograms per battery that means a lot
more cobalt mined as more electric cars
are sold this may look like a double-a
battery but it's the sort of fuel cell
you'll find in an electric vehicle
researchers here in University College
London are stripping it down to measure
how much cobalt it contains companies
and universities like ours are trying to
reduce the amount of cobalt that's being
used in these different battery
chemistry's but in the near future we
can expect there's going to be a
significant amount of COBOL demand to
service the lithium ion battery market
as it continues to grow with the growth
of the electric vehicle market the
smartphone revolution is already 10
years old the devices we now delight in
are impossibly sleek and powerful
for the brutal conditions that make them
possible still seem like the relic of
another age Tom Cheshire Sky News